biology often gets a bit of a bad rep
especially from people interested in
physics I think the reason why is sort
of summed up in the quote from Ernest
Rutherford that all science is either
physics or stamp collecting often when
we first learn about biology it's more
to do with memorizing lots of discrete
things whether it's words or functions
and it seems a little bit unsatisfying
in the sense that there doesn't seem to
be many unifying principle involved
however if you look a bit closer at
biology there are some unifying ideas
one of which is life itself and the fact
that life evolves or that genetic
information changes over time in this
video I'm going to take a bit of a dive
into the field of computational biology
showing you the intersection of biology
with math physics and computer science I
think that there is overlap between
these fields are probably a lot more
than you think and this is a
continuation of my study with me series
so I'm not necessarily an expert on this
topic but hopefully we can learn
together here I'm working through the
computational biology course on
brilliant org and a link to this course
will be down the description so you can
follow along if you want to this page is
talking about Charles Darwin and how he
was trying to find similarities or
relatedness between different bird
species and he was doing this with the
finches by looking at I guess the shapes
of their beaks and trying to find a
unification there some of Darwin's
theories were not necessarily convincing
because looking for shared features like
this is not something that you can do
with all organisms however if you get
closer and I'm talking to the small
scale of like DNA and molecules we do
see a similarity between all life-forms
and that's that all life from bacteria
to dinosaurs have a DNA genome and uses
this genetic and
information to program the cells to do
things like make proteins RNA everything
else that makes up the organism this is
a way to connect the family trees of
organisms that might not otherwise seem
to be related at all we can connect them
to having a common ancestor which also
had DNA looking down to genetic
information actually gives us a lot to
work with in biology it is something
that is discrete and you can quantify it
we have a page here about the human
genome project so this is something that
has given us you know a lot of
information to work with we have the
complete genomes of hundreds of animals
and plants each consisting of gigabytes
of data so we have all of this
information now it says here that this
rise in genetic sequencing has been a
gold rush for information theorists
renewing the techniques that were used
in communications signal processing and
statistical physics for this new
frontier of biological information so
now that we have all this data what
problems should biology research be
focusing on to make the most of it and I
guess we're going to have a look at some
of those ideas throughout the rest of
this video genetic sequencing really
does provide the motivation for
mathematicians physicists computer
scientists whoever to really become
interested in biological problems which
I guess beforehand did give it that
reputation of stamp collecting which I
don't think applies anymore one idea
that we can start the shed some light on
is the connection between genetic
information and biological structures so
all humans are like 99.9% genetically
similar but we see huge differences
between us or they might look huge but
they're down to you know very small
differences in our genetic makeup these
differences come mostly from random
genetic mutations throughout human
history one thing to note though is that
genetic code is surprisingly
error tolerant
- mutations especially - single
nucleotide mutations which are the
mutations described here on this page
where we have one base incorrectly
becoming another base so just as a quick
refresher we have DNA which is made up
of in this case four bases a T G and C
and they pair with each other to form
this double helix set of instructions
for ourselves so what goes on a lot in
ourselves is that we have to copy make
new copies of DNA and during that
process is always room for some
mutations or for things to go slightly
wrong so you can see in this example
here we have two sequences of DNA and
there are eight mutations which are in
the red so these don't match up and
there are seven matches so at least
eight mutation events have happened
getting from sequence 1 to sequence 2 it
goes on to say that mistakes at the DNA
level don't always translate to mistakes
and protein blueprints so this DNA here
is coding for a protein to be made in a
cell in fact the instructions that cells
follow to change a DNA sequence into a
protein is often very robust to these
mutations so we can even use the
translation function and pison below to
find the protein encoded by these two
strings of DNA throughout this
computational biology course you can
learn how to build your own functions in
Python which is a coding language and
very useful for science but we're going
to just look at how useful having
something like this a coding language
can be to understanding some of these
biological ideas so for now we're just
going to click run code but if you're
interested you can come on to brilliant
and have a look at this code and you can
even learn sort of the fundamentals of
Python yourself through some of their
other courses to actually understand
what's going on here this code is going
to replicate the biological process of
translation which we
DNA three letters at a time each three
letters corresponds to an amino acid and
we string all these amino acids together
to make up our protein so let's see how
you do that in code we're defining our
two DNA sequences to be translated we
then define a function and translate
which takes that DNA that we've defined
and outputs our translated protein
sequence at the end it returns it we
then are making a dictionary which is
storing each combination of three bits
of DNA three bases and what component of
the protein they would make so I guess
what amino acid we are then going to
iterate through our DNA sequence three
letters at a time until the end and for
each triplet of DNA we're going to
append that corresponding protein letter
from our dictionary to our growing
protein sequence then at the end we're
just going to return the translated
protein sequence and what we get out is
that both of our sequences that we saw
before translate into exactly the same
protein the protein is called salty here
and each letter of salty is made up of a
triplet of DNA so that's pretty cool but
what is really surprising is that
through these sequences even though
there were eight single mutations and
differences between them at the end of
translation they actually make exactly
the same protein so that's what I mean
about it being sort of error tolerant we
can take another look at the power of
some of these computational tools in our
next example here and this one is all
about Katz my favorite animal and it's
about something called polydactyly which
is when an individual has an excessive
number of fingers or toes cats typically
have 18 toes but a cat with this
condition has four extra toes a total of
22 so this condition is caused by
mutation
and this time the mutations are
propagating through to actually change
the individual what it looks like we can
use a combination of coding on Python
and some statistical methods to actually
find out you know where the offending
mutation occurs in the DNA of the cats
so the way we're going to do this is to
compare the genetic sequence of five
control cats and five affected cats yep
so we track down the exact position
where the mutation can result in extra
toes so let's just have a look through
some of the notes of what's going on in
this bit of Python here again don't
worry about understanding it all step by
step now you can take a look at this
yourself this is just to illustrate the
power of some of these tools so first of
all we're going to define two sets of
DNA we've got some DNA from control cats
and some from the affected cats we're
then defining a function frequency lists
which is collecting statistical
information about the DNA nucleotides or
the bases in each position of the
sequence so we're trying to figure out
do some parts of the sequence tend to be
different for the polydactyl cats we go
through there and for each nucleotide at
each each position we run a statistical
test in this case we're actually running
the Tri squared test which you might
have heard of if you've done a bit of
Statistics and we're using that to
determine whether there is a significant
difference in frequency between the
control and the case cats yep as well as
using tri squared we're also looking at
the p-values we want your p-value to be
low kind of indicates that what you've
seen is not just due to random chance
then at the end we're just printing the
positions and the nucleotides which
showed the most statistical difference
between the case cats and the control
cats and we're printing the p-value so
this is our output here we have four
different potentially offending
nucleotide bases or changes in the base
we have the position and the D
a sequence where it occurs and the
p-value or how likely it is to be
basically causing this condition and the
cats so our lowest p-value here is for
the first and third option which means
that at position 81 there definitely
seems to be something going on and it
looks like we have had a change from an
A to a G nucleotide so that's just an
example of how we can start to sort
through all this information that we
have and start to get some useful
results out of it that actually give us
insight into what's really going on
how does genetic information lead to
changes and what we're seeing in
individuals the brilliant course goes
more in-depth into connecting genetic
information with biological structure
whilst introducing the Python language
for beginner programmers so if you would
like to work through the rest of this at
your own pace you can go to brilliant
org slash Tibby's and sign up for free
also the first 200 people to do so can
get 20% off an annual premium
subscription thank you to brilliant for
sponsoring this video and thank you for
watching
you